I took some action today talked to my
son this morning told him I was sorry
for being a dick that's humongous yeah
so USG made an impct straight away that
means the world to me you can't imagine
how big of a deal that will be thank you
you're you know how much he appreciated
that absolutely absolutely good for you
God bless the world parents and manages
and runs governments and companies
predominantly weaponizing fear fear is
the currency of our world we're going to
cancel you or shame you we're going to
call you bad how many people here are
parents raise your hands think for a
second of the things that come out of
your mouth if you you better not by the
way it works in the short term the
problem is it doesn't work in the long
term it leads to massive resentment it
leads to underperforming we've been sold
a bag of where your growth is
going to be is continuity and growth of
your people when people are happy they
perform better not when they're
scared